[Music]
[Music]
so the thing days what's it all for
and well we admire achievers from James
Watt to Mandela Mary Curie to Emmeline
Pankhurst and we in school and encourage
our children to be similarly focused yet
many spend their lives waiting for
weekends and holidays and does not play
both as sex drugs and rock and roll and
as a creative and physical endeavor
provide us with the most memorable
events in life so should we embrace play
as the most important activity in life
and abandon work and achievement as a
mug's game well with me to talk about
this we have an excellent panel so am i
right is Susan Nieman moral philosopher
cultural commentator essayist and the
author of the recent book why grow up an
excellent book to my left
yeah nutella writer who's write novels
essay short stories often on existential
themes and among her many awards is the
dressage prize for literary works
towards peace and human understanding
and finally to my left hand and Lederer
comedian writer and actor best known
perhaps for absolutely fabulous French
and Saunders and girls on top so to
begin with we begin by just asking each
of the panelists to set out their basic
views on this topic we're there sort of
like the slightly provocative question
perhaps should we just basically give up
work as a mug's game and really focus
our lives around play Susan what do you
make of that
I need the wrong question as you you ask
a philosopher that's what you get I mean
as you know because I think we met when
I was talking about my book
why grow up as you know which is I guess
the reason why I was invited to this
particular panel I I am outraged at the
way we have given adulthood a bad rap
and I think there's something about the
way the question is phrased which
suggests
actually adulthood is a tired dull
miserable state of being and we should
all go back to childhood and the
interesting thing is no child wants to
stay a child okay oh it's really true
those of you who've had them will will
agree and moreover when people go on
about how awful it is to grow up or to
become an adult the phase that they
usually idealize is the phase between
about eighteen and twenty eight
I don't know how many of you are looking
at the audience most of you are past
that particular phase it's not all of
you now actually there comes you and and
look if if you're had good times in your
20s power to you but most people I know
once they're out of them would never
choose to repeat them again it's a
terribly hard time of life you're
figuring out who you are and what you
want to do with your life and I really
think the whole point of this propaganda
that you know the fun and games the play
is over at thirty and after that it's
time to get on to the serious and rather
miserable business of living is a way of
since it's just empirically false
I mean they've even been social
psychologists do Studies on happiness
there's a happiness curve that people
actually get progressively unhappier
it's different for different countries I
think the Swiss are the worst it takes
it takes them much longer to go up the
curve again then it does some other
people but so there's all kinds of
empirical evidence that youth is not
actually the best time of your life so
the question is why are we being sold
this bill of goods and I think it's to
make us resigned to accepting the world
as it is let me just say one more thing
as a way of answering the official
question
was posed about the opposition between
work and play if you talked to a real
activist I've never met Mandela but I
know a number of people who've given
serious amounts of their lives and gone
to jail for some question of justice and
they were passionately committed to they
will talk about not sacrifice but a
feeling of freedom and a feeling of deep
deep I'm not sure they didn't use the
word happiness but joy at being able to
do that so the weird thing about the way
the question was phrased was that you
juxtapose you know someone like Mandela
or Pankhurst and and then you talk about
sex drugs drugs and rock and roll
nothing against any of them by the way I
mean we we're throwing a lot of
different different ideas into a mix
where they don't belong and I think it's
important to distinguish between them
okay Helen yeah well I'm gonna have a
goat deconstructing the question I think
that's a brilliant start my
understanding of the question was that
you had to have either/or that you have
a worry that you have to replace work
with play or one or the other
so I would my position here is as a
comedian as somebody who was always um
well fat asthmatic with a hairband
obviously great criteria for being the
comedian so I was the funny one in the
class the other fat person wasn't funny
we're two of us but um so I've
understood how play has fed into my work
so I have to be playful in order to work
at my best and if you think about the
role of yo caught gestures I actually
googled this that's the only way I
actually access information and like my
colleagues that the court gesture was
obviously there there was a woman court
jester called Jane by the way in Mary
the first that's as far as I've googled
but the point is - it's a leveler of
society playfulness as a level of
society to sort of prevent dogmatism so
there's that then
like gender thing that men like Rod
Stewart can play with his train sets and
actually donate money to a museum I
don't if anyone read that recently when
there was a quel desastre broken down
trains or something anyway whereas
women's play is seen as having to be
restorative or improving so we need to
actually get a kind of traditional
gender look at how place it's in society
then because more of us are going to be
out of work or more of us are freelance
play is very very essential for our
mental stability because of being
isolated so I would say play is part of
work not to exchange I think I think
some people are greedy yeah well as a
fiction writer I was that somewhere else
with a statement from one of my book
saying nothing matters I've known that
for a long time so it's not worth doing
anything I just realized that these are
the words of a 14 year old boy who
decides to leave school because of what
he thinks and he climbs a plum tree
where his friends pass on the way to
school and he say things to them like
the earth is 4.6 billion years old and
you will live maximum 100 life really
isn't worth the bother and they set up
to prove to him therefore that life has
a meaning and a lot of things happen but
to come then back to the question if
absolutely nothing matters then also
neither work nor play matter and to know
whether work or play matters we need to
know what is the real purpose of
something because if we just do things
to waste time in any way it doesn't
really matter if it's fun or not we're
just wasting time so if we imagine there
is a purpose and again people who fight
I think for something they believe in
then everything they do to that end
makes sense you know and therefore also
sound if you believe that humor is the
way
to make the world more peaceful and go
around because it's smooth interactions
over in a positive way then a lot of
humor and play make sense and I think
when something makes sense to us it is
always joyful a tedious thing can be
pretty joyful if it makes sense like
taking care of your child's I have a
horse and a lot of tedious things to do
with taking care of a horse but I
actually enjoy most of them and so I
think this thing of making sense comes
in and then I will also decompose
something so I would take the work play
because I play a lot when I write
fiction but it's towards a certain end I
think it's quite different than if one
maybe jumps Bunge jumps and just want to
try it out or if you do like futile fun
games but still if it's for the purpose
of your family having a social evening
you know something else comes into it so
that's why I just think we have to see
what is the purpose of the bigger thing
before we can judge what is better than
not okay well if there's food rangers
who starting point so i have to say now
the thing is to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit a I
dot TV for more debates and talks from
the world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas